[Applaudissements]
vous avez vu cette équipe de bras cassés
faut pas travailler pour toi c'est en
compte un maillot alors avait réjoui on
en prend plein la gueule ici et on
applaudit en plus après vais tout voir
je vais vous dire philippe candeloro a
fait quelque chose pour vous
[Applaudissements]
quatre heures payées demain
[Rires]
bon bah passez-moi 50 euros j'étais pas
là
mais je te dépasse mais tu m'as vite on
reste wallon alors ils passent mais il
m'a vite fait voilà [ __ ] je vois par
cas d'accès m'emmerde ses bras ses
cadeaux vous n'avez pas un truc sur
nelson monfort qu'on sait pas qu'on
pourra lui sortir la semaine prochaine
comme vous savez pas vous savez tout sur
nelson mais ya pas une petite anecdote
je sais pas il connaît bien des blagues
de cul demandé les kilos raconte une
valérie bénaïm ou enora malagré les deux
en même temps c'est bien